game number six usually that's what
comes after game number five and we're
going to have a super quick version
analysis of this one basically just like
game five same story equal slightly
better more slightly better that draw
end game blunder winning okay I'll see
you Wednesday
for for game seven and that's true like
Jacob if I said something that was not
totally precise describing the game okay
okay you know Alex got me a tuna salad
and now I I have to slave it over and so
food analysis of the game I haven't
seen
no
amazing
more no no no no that's that's amazing
so R who has white color who has white
color it says Carlon this color and an
white wonderful so he's pushing him with
the
Berlin D3 but speak speaking from
opening point of view I was actually
thinking that he should play D4
like I actually did even the first E4
that he played I didn't really
understand the the problems with
E4 is that there are just some lines
many lines that just kind of kind of
kill the game in some way like the
Berlin okay you want to play the Berlin
play the Berlin but okay it's I think
only opening in chest that I've never
really analyzed don't want to analyze
wouldn't analyze no like I don't know
kind of no fun but apparently for kamnik
it meant world championship and against
Carson is also meaning World Champ being
world
champion
so there was Kasparov wrote a bit right
he said for Anan don't do the mistake I
did son well maybe the son I added but
uh just basically like don't be stubborn
and you know try to crack the Berlin
play something else kaspar couldn't do
it one one game against Kik maybe you
know play the C I mean find some ideas
have your team find some ideas somewhere
I don't know play Queens play king's
Gambit with some new ideas play the
Vienna but main stream Main Line Berlin
No what nothing I mean you have to play
the line that he play today and that
they never play that that pawn to Queen
Rook or what that F4 no no in the Berlin
that other line you showed the last time
doesn't seem like they play that very
frequently wait oh oh the you mean take
and Rook e
one casual yeah you take and then oh
yeah this line they used to play that
but I was think oh oh oh oh oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this oops yeah yeah
yeah this line you see it someone a True
Believer and follower they don't play
that very often yeah and Andre can beat
we mentioned andrein beat kamnik and
just now in the Russian
Championship maybe probably is better
than the other one going to the end game
well the thing the thing is that this
probably goes to another end game
straight you know just just one that we
don't trading Queens immediately though
yeah well trading Queens there's nothing
wrong with trading Queens trading Queens
into nothing that's the problem yeah
trading Queens into some Advantage is
cool but okay I mean you you're playing
World Championship Match you have a team
of several very strong Grand Masters
working for
you get them find something find
something you know even if objectively
it's a draw find something that is
impossible for on the board to find a
draw some come with something come up
with something no nothing were there any
like Novelties in this game
or yes big one huge one coming soon
meaningless one but coming
soon yeah but I mean at least in D4 I
think you you have some some territory
that you can maybe
get more game it's not really like that
decisive into okay end game d sh game or
something like this you want to go even
into more Uncharted Territory play C4
and go to some englishes or whatever
just
something you know but no I was
surprised with E4 at all so this is what
they
play and now rookie yeah there' have
been lines of D6 and so
on okay you know Aran is the the the do
to follow
here okay
novelty Anan comes up with new if not
especially surprising new move again
Carson had been following a recent Anan
game against Aran from alakan Memorial
in
April what what I was just saying that's
it Bishop G novelty like never does
anything in
these from yeah so Knight bd2 was played
in that game and you know like um how
Seinfeld once described this show it's a
show about nothing exactly it's a show
about nothing nothing what what you
nothing a show about nothing yeah this
is this
line This is this line it's a line about
nothing so yeah I mean okay you know
Knight bd2 not not even not even moving
the pieces here okay okay I'll move the
pieces maybe in hopes of another tunal
before next lecture Knight F1 knight7
okay yada yada yada and
door
like yeah only I'm not certain that
Carson has seen this episode but because
apparently he wanted to win but okay
Bishop
G5 so okay if
H4 I guess he would just go back and be
similar to the game it was interesting I
was looking with v today we're doing it
live on IC okay to me they said that
Bishop E6 was computer Choice number
eight eight to me I see two moves in the
position and again it's just my
ignorance and understanding I play H6
well maybe he doesn't see I'll take the
bishop and if not okay I want to block
this diagonal I play Bishop B6 and okay
probably not best but I don't know just
looks simple you know Aran has so many
games in this in those lines in the way
lupz different version the anti musle
system he pretty much never something
important when you see this
one you don't want to get the bishop
here when you want to get the bishop on
B7 when this Pawn is on D4 cuz then
you're actually targeting E4 if the pawn
on D3 Bishop B7 no good the Same by the
way if the pawn is on
D4 Bishop G4 is good or decent why
because then you are putting pressure on
the Knight and putting pressure on D4 if
the pawn is on D3 you will just be metad
with H3 and G4 because the center is so
solid and you will have a very blocked
Bishop there so this just really
important to understand why many times
you don't see Bishop B7 when Pawn is on
D3 Aran pretty much never plays this and
many other players that's I think right
approach so Bishop B6 for an ignorant
like me was just natural and computers
were suggesting Rook B8 h I don't know
Bishop
E6 so here were some interesting lines
if take probably has to take with the
pawn I mean this is maybe not so cool
some ideas like this and they'll follow
with
D5 not so so
cool there are some lines like this
but it has to be bad for black like
probably really bad for
black
unless
unless there is this ugly move and then
I'm taking it back and actually should
call Vu and tell him that we both didn't
see anything during our life
show I was I was following it
withot andini and rookie was one of
their suggestions two of them suggested
FES one of them suggested okay so
apparently Rook take is okay and the
computer didn't blunder like plus
three yeah we
you see the magic of the St Louis chest
lab you know couldn't see it on IC see
here everything is so simple it's it's
so
clear so clear well it might also has to
do with the part that now it's
2:30 in the afternoon and not 2:30 at
night no it's the
lighting it's the what it's the
lighting you said it so apparently that
was possible no okay Bishop B6 is normal
what what do they want oh okay and take
that was Tiny
surprising okay Pawn take is logical but
here this kid has potential he played no
such a great move like
wow Jacob ning his head so don't say a
word here we will let Alex that we've
all gathered here to give him a brief
analysis of the game tell us what would
you play with
black no this amazing how huh huh Bishop
B6 Bishop B6 actually not bad move that
was the aian suggestion so not bad but
you don't want to play like V you want
to play like
Magnus come
on so what do we have
here
for
yes any
thought I'm trying to find something I
would nor play May E6
no okay it it's a very cool move super
cool
move
very nice c not to C5 just to D7 and for
people that know the Brier variation
okay
let's let's let's show quickly the B
variation anandan car had many games we
many games in 2010 in the bio variation
which is a major a major response to the
main line in the r
lupz and Carson mentioned this himself
after all I know the Brier so but still
the the fact that he connected that
ideas big
potential so this is the main position
in the r lupz for a long time and kpov
had many many game in the zit variation
Knight A5 is chori and kpov also played
Knight D7 no Knight B8 is a very kind of
like very popular move mainly because of
car and many games
2010 csky played this kov used to play
some games like this before like in the'
70s this many great players like what is
the
idea open the diagonal for the
bishop and put the Knight on D7 where it
kind of coordinates well with the other
pieces also not
blocking the C Pawn it's a big line very
very very big line and I think in 2010
Anand en Carson played four or five
games just in that position like that
was
really
so very very nice for Alex I mean this
is just a great move I mean solve all
the problems me and V were looking at
some lines like here and here and then
if G5 some captures and ah you know he
doesn't even want to look at that and I
mean this is just absolutely great so
just no problems but now seriously like
is this position it should be losing
with white I mean that's the thing if
you lose here that's it you know there's
no no
nowhere I mean okay
okay okay okay of course A5
automatically A5 right automatically
getting rid of the weakness right you
played before before it's is going to
get something just get rid of the
weakness I will give it to VAR by the
way which move here we're going to play
automatically oh maybe not automatically
but still super reasonably
okay
yes Alex you you're hitting it right on
so no yes you only you come on like
night Knight B8 and now you are
quiet I would play night
G4
Bishop I seen that you took every
everything I believed in
no okay what is the bishop doing
here okay put it
here but now seriously okay so we said
it's a draw and I will say that VAR said
maybe black is Tiny
better but okay we played and like just
showed it's kind of okay take take no
the problem is there is no Knight D5
because F2 is hanging that's a big
one but dude
like what's that I mean okay like
seriously play here here something like
this this no if if I mean I understand
maybe black is Bishop is tiny tiny tiny
better than white but okay you know
let's play this queen E2
move and see
that 0 00 0 0000 0 not enough zeros
there to continue now does it mean that
Carson might not outplay and beat
someone like me in this position of
course of course it's possible of course
it even more likely than not likely but
he should not be able to outplay the
world champion in this position no now
that that's the thing yes of
course it's a game objectively it's
completely okay for white like where are
the weaknesses nothing like why why
should white be losing this game why
there has to be reason it's not like
well
randomly no and the world champion is
there and you cannot you cannot be world
champion and lose those positions I mean
that this is much this is really serious
I mean okay it's not serious it's over
the match is over the match I thought
was over quite before but it's kind
of I might even say tiny
embarrassing because if in the previous
game we can say that okay white was tiny
tiny better the pawn on C6 was was weak
he put some pressure they got into equal
and he played one wrong move you cannot
I mean it's tiny not so cool you know to
lose such
position he played Queen G4 and here you
know this is how fish Fisher said how
you win games with black you know how
you win games with black what Fisher
said first you equalize so that stage
already passed now possibility to get
microscopic advantage
take I have to take with the
pawn okay
so not that great I mean I mean still
incredible
unbelievable not that great I mean black
is already like this better and we were
speaking with VAR is it going to be a
draw or not and Caron just well that's
why he the greatest player today just
hit all the right points he said look
Anand is upset after yesterday game
black black objectively is
microscopically better objectively I
mean he he has some plans the
center the white pawns are somewhat weak
yeah of course it should be a draw
but but Anand also upset I mean maybe if
yesterday game was draw maybe they
wouldn't even be battling here but well
he understands everything look F1
C5
and tiny bit more tiny bit more so now
this is becoming weak weak Wecker I mean
it's again putting numbers okay we are
at the zero a vast virus database has
upd apparently my database is updated
all
right chess base tweak is updated no
okay
but yeah I mean is there C5 C4
okay D4 was played actually here was
really big moment that I wanted to say
two parts like me and V but I will say
one part like me V is not in that group
like why not
D5 why not
D5 not clear right I mean just D5 and
and the thing is
that there will be some counterplay for
white here when if black just decides to
go all over there so D5 we
like and you play kind of like okay
please please please play D5 like okay
but why
not no like this this
bizarre I mean it's amazing
how how Anand is not in control is is
not in control in when basically the in
a big game of chess there are many
important decisions to take exchange not
exchange close the structure not close
the structure Anand kind of chose not to
do anything not to do anything he say
okay my the position is okay and is
right I'll make a
draw okay but why not
the5 okay now another very important
moment which
is why to
play
okay what is the obvious move the obv
queen D1 but I don't
likeing no but Queen D1 is really bad I
just play D5 yeah or might be really
bad D5 Rook D5 yeah for example Queen D1
I just might play here and for this is
probably probably just lost like this or
here like this king is not so cool over
there something like that is going to be
evil yeah Rook D5 is very critical you
know we were here teaching some kids and
something like about
exchanges exchanges are always critical
the less pieces are on the board
exchanges becomes a matter of life and
death I mean seriously if you exchange
right piece to draw that's it maybe if
you don't exchange it also that's it or
maybe if you exchange to a loft end game
that's it when they are very much
reduced material it's kind of clear
conclusion like if you say someone
looking at a simple P game and say why
it's better it's kind of ridiculous
right I mean you want yes or no there is
no in most end most simple end games
there is no well it's better funny Rook
D5 was probably drawish like we looked
at this position I mean okay I'm not
going to analyze this super duper deeply
but it looked like it should be okay
this end game it looked like it King f8
I don't look like some smart people
think it might be reasonable well okay
actually not smart people but maybe but
here is a decision King
H1 okay so now you don't have this
anymore didn't he move his King twice
like that he he just played now many
moves meaningless he's going to move
wait you're going to enjoy the rest so
look look at the what he's playing here
here and that's triangulation with the
king and queen no but what what can he
play he he missed the opportunity that
he had and once again critical moment to
to see what's happening with the
exchanges of the Rooks he had this
opportunity and he missed
it but still the question is how is
black going to get something here
and here we played Queen
G3 and this
is
interesting yeah I
mean you know sometimes you really have
to do nothing and see if your opponent
can break through it's very important
it's just very important many people
I've seen many many people no not uh no
not 2800 no but many Club players
whatever level they are that the
position is kind of all right but they
just don't feel right with the concept
of doing nothing the concept of I just
sit and wait and don't hurt the position
just sit and wait and don't hurt the
position you
know what computers say here for white
but this is also what we
thought King G1 H5 King H2 Ken f8 Queen
F4 King G1 King H1 King
H2 that's the end of the line but
basically you
know amazing now was the time to do
nothing because black has some weakness
here and it's not really easy for him to
go after this one it's probably draw I
mean yes black is 03 04 better no
computer wise I mean okay of course for
a human it's not that easy but it's up
to Black to show he has a plan it's up
for black to show that he can really get
something here and I don't think
so this move was played and it's losing
a pawn and now important thing if
take this is a draw
this and now how to make a draw the most
comfortable way I mean maybe best maybe
only way but just clearly making a
draw you know
huh yeah Rook D4 and after Rook D take
B3 yeah three against two you know I was
picking with varou said oh we can still
play this I was telling you no no I mean
he said they can still I mean if this is
the best this is the best and whatever
and I was telling him okay I I put one
to 100 with you right now that Anand is
not going to lose this
one I mean okay you know can I told him
I'll put one to 200 I mean probably I
should have made it five I could have
gotten frozen yogurt five to 500 no this
Anand would not lose billion out of
billion you he would not lose this yeah
was there was that there was that
Nakamura Carlson game where Nakamura had
like RI and two versus rook and one and
he lost oh but but but the Blitz game
right yeah oh that that that that was
that was insane insane I mean I couldn't
believe that I've seen the position and
I've seen the score and I went over it
and I said no was the flagged he lost on
the board yeah but but that was kind of
blit and he tried to win like insanely
yeah but of course if you simplify to
one side it's that's actually important
line to say because once again I found a
BFF in analysis not a bad one iaro
because I was advocating during the
analysis with VAR just going to two
versus one or sorry two h and f or three
versus one on one side and just make a
draw any car after it like I mean may
maybe I mean before but was kept saying
no why why did when when the position
was Lo why did he play that why not just
we will see that so he took and took
first
here okay it's a pawn it's a pawn but
he's a bit tied here he's a bit tied
here no all
right Rook D6 not allowing the king out
okay this was an idea I mean it's still
it still looks very much in a dsh
territory here was
actually
here was actually very very critical
point by the way computers are in a deut
territory so Anand was right by the way
I mean he was right he understand he
understood that he has enough counter
player for a draw okay we told you you
know we kind of bash him and no okay he
doesn't deserve this to be honest but I
mean he's such a great genius player but
it it sometimes feels like how to say it
like you know there are some boxers that
fought few fights more than they should
and they kind of paid more serious price
than few rating points right those that
didn't retire on time I mean Anand okay
he cannot retire as the world champion
really it doesn't work that way but I
just at least hopefully he's going to
get some dignity in the match you know
if he will win one despite the fact that
my prediction and like very house thing
will proven wrong it will be good you
know he deserve that as a such a great
chess player he doesn't deserve to lose
the game the match in because he might
he might lose minus three he might lose
minus four not so cool no he he deserve
better than this I think so here again
it's just a draw I mean
okay C play King F7
and H5 they said suggested some ideas
like tiny improving the pieces but it's
still a draw white is just Rook on B6
and bring the king to F3 and we we
didn't really see any any concrete
winning plan although of course it's a
big play I mean Carson will play for two
three hours and probably beat most
players in the world somehow
but yeah and here an UNL H5 and you know
people were asking him uh you know after
like why you gave the pawn and no okay I
mean po Anna like really didn't want to
be there some some days like that but
that's a good move actually I mean
that's a very decent move it's just at
this point I I missed the all H5 idea
this cars anything I didn't think you
can really give up a pawn like this now
it was a
draw okay I
mean I mean you you cannot make too many
of those mistakes in a match against
Carlson yeah and this is the moment like
for example or many others moment after
it like dude
just something like this I guess like I
don't know I mean this has to
be super duper theoretically draw I mean
it has to
be that's it right I
mean we don't need to
be we don't need to be un and you know
what I will even say that even don't
need to be hikaro to to say no that this
is a draw we kind of suggested it yeah
it's a draw I mean of course it can be
played of course you know uh even the
h&f which is theoretical draw Kik bonan
but it's a draw it's a draw and it's a
theoretical draw on one side of the
board so you don't need to have some
super amazing things but okay I can
understand him not going there although
he just finishes every
tactics so he played this move
okay
aha yeah this check you know it's B
Bobby Fisher that says a p sees a check
a p give the check right and he he meant
about one of his games that he
play but making it much more much more
difficult like I mean Rook C8 not
allowing the king to cross is just
simple draw I mean he has to go back and
how is he going to really improve here
black not easy not to mention that at
any given moment we can maybe make
effort to play B3 and go back to our old
position instead it's the last possible
imaginable trick in the position it's
like it's after you know after overtime
overtime again you know like this like
everyone is leaving the field like we
were saying like kind of okay it's a DW
but okay
here okay and here here he has some
troubles because you cannot without
those pawns it's probably an easy draw
without those pawns because the Rook is
just
checking without those pawns it's an
easy draw he's just going to be checking
him with the rook and defending
everything and okay those are Double H
pawns
like kind of kind of I mean let's let's
for a second oh I cannot um set the
position but without those pawns here
maybe let's do it beautifully for a
second I will make those pawns
disappear okay okay kids don't try this
at home okay this position no okay
check
check okay I don't know something like
this
maybe like this I mean maybe maybe here
I allowed H3 so I should not allow this
actually I should probably play here
tiny maybe here why should I allow your
king there let me play no maybe I should
get my king from here you know because
H3 is an idea but maybe just this
move I mean I think this should be a
draw it should be a draw though I don't
I don't like my king getting cut this
way you know with something evil like
that okay he he has he has to play a bit
more accurate than just just moving the
pieces but it should be they said it
should be a draw and I kind of easily
beli
them
instead R you res
all right yeah we could Analyze This
Rook end game but I'm going to leave it
to some people in a better uh uh less
important things to do such as getting
sleep
but and here there was one move only one
move to make a draw so once again Rook
A1 in previous game was pretty only move
to make a draw and here one only move to
make a draw and it's not Rook
A4 it was B4 well you want to keep the r
on the
rank so that after something like this
H3 and here I think he wanted to go down
with the Rook right I think that was the
analysis I'm going
to I think that was this okay F4 Carlson
only said maybe when ask if he thought
the position was winning without this
Pawn B2 and C3 it would be a dead draw
Carson but this Pawn seriously
inhibit the rook and H3 F H3 F3 is
coming
fast now it's interesting Kon thought
said oh no it's lost just doing like
this with the hand and Anan said no and
here I was lost but interesting that
they both didn't both players thought
this idea was too slow but it seems to
be a draw B4 H3 Rook G6 Rook
C7 Rook C7 maybe no difference if
C8 King d
D3 B5
F3
sorry uh sorry Rook F3 first yeah of
course I didn't understand why King D3
just overlooked this this Rook
F7
yeah and notice white white gets a lot
of counter play I mean you know yo
joking no joking always say when we on
quoting Alin I was not once P Pawn
should be pushed no but P Pawn should be
pushed you know this is really every
Russian school boy knows maybe not a
world champion from India like P pawns
should be pushed I mean I've seen some
people say know every half of the
2400 player in Moscow would make draw
easy draw with white I think so I mean I
don't know it's like maybe they didn't
lose a game before maybe they're not aan
maybe all the stress is coming to him I
mean and I don't think that aan 10 years
ago would have lost any of those
positions pretty much there is one very
notorious end game that he lost to Leo
three against three and an a pawn
but anyway Rook A4 just
lost he's just lost now
yeah and here just nothing to look I
mean I mean if Rook E1 this is the big
idea King on H2 is
disgusting
enough no very very kind of set game you
know like it was symmetrical symmetrical
equal he played C4 black was zero2
better white had many possibilities to
even not get into a pawn down he got
into a pawn down and an un played really
okay he had enough chances he had always
enough counterplay for a draw at no
point other than the last point he was
lost at no point at no point it was even
much worse he was a pawn down but always
The Rook was tied to B5 H5 was
good it's kind of kind
of how the game deteriorated was one
thing
I said I think I said something on move
57 50 whatever we spoke with VAR and I
said well it's going to be a draw well
just before he blundered it's a draw
Anan played bad but not bad enough to
lose the game well yeah he played Rook
A4 so but but that but that was really
the story of the game up until then you
know even if he had made a draw he
played bad just not bad enough to lose
he was outplayed in the opening and some
part of the middle game but then then he
had to R A for in yeah I think I think
he kind of understand that the match
is that the match looks over I mean may
maybe this is what will he will play
maybe now really all in and maybe we
will see tiny bit different game maybe
but I don't think it's going to help him
at all so okay well we'll be here on
Wednesday how many more games we're
going to have two more games and we'll
see we'll see how it goes